[Applause]
irving
pep in his step oh the corkscrew off the
euro
kyrie irving is locked in
the nets take a two-point lead an
elusive move from kyrie
[Music]
kyrie irving 34 points
leonard short on a three rebounded by
harris
net 7-0 run kyrie irving has
37 points but two misses on a three ball
we approach four minutes to go
in the fourth james harden got a three
kawhi he's 29.
[Applause]
now durant wants to get in on the act
durant's jumper
is good
it and clears under two minutes to play
durant wants to dance with batum a three
kevin durant a downtown hit
let's find themselves in another
potentially hairy situation harden goes
long
green ball fake layup is good and a foul
with 5.5 harden throws the touchdown
pass
to jeff green brooklyn in the same
position they were in
two nights ago jeff green wide open and
it looked like he didn't even really
want to shoot that right there but
knocks down the layup great pass by
hardin
another down the road non-regular season